but very influential if you look at the
fan the wrestlemania fan festival if you
what we do with skank fest like that was
like one of the best memories the
wrestlemania fans festival you show up
and it's not just [ __ ] like
autographs they have a lot of
interactive [ __ ] you know you're like
you know you're you're meeting the
wrestlers you do meet and greets and
[ __ ] but they're like doing [ __ ]
other things it's like shows have no
it's hilarious stan hope goes on rogan
and brings up how cool skank fest is
ridiculous and then rogen just shuts it
down immediately and goes you should do
your own fast
and he's trying to like have a nice
pitch
it's a nice pitch
he's like i did this festival it's just
the greatest thing ever yeah rogan's
like he was like he was like oh yeah
he's like that's really probably because
the comedy scene down in houston is
great it's like there's nothing to do
with the comedy scene yeah it's [ __ ]
houston it's nothing we booked three
comics from houston we brought the
[ __ ] greatest comics from the world
mostly from new york city to houston
[ __ ] did the most unique fun
interactive craziest comedy festival
ever yeah but doug stand up should just
steal the idea yeah
you should just take it
joe's like you should do your own the
same guy who assaulted carlos mancia for
stealing a shitty ari shafir joke
the shitty as sorry is your fear joke
that's ever been [ __ ] written
well he stole more than that i know he
didn't like he's older right but you
know that was a straw though
you know yeah
no no no no we love him but i mean it is
funny that he was just like
steal it do you wrong
well it's not stealing you just said do
your own fast i think no i i think he's
a little disconnected from what
skankfest is i think he thinks like
that's what bert's doing by the way i
hope he's just he's got uh he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars i hope
he's disconnected from it yeah but i
mean like bert you know bert's doing his
own festival it's not the same thing
though right it's not there's there's
nothing like scary face you gotta go and
see it and know what it is in order to
[ __ ] and then what is what would you
say the difference with skankfest is
it's if people get raped party it's a
part well yeah well they don't tell yeah
it's a party here's the thing with all
things the [ __ ] whatever they call it
the uh that's what is the joke festival
here's what i will say about scanning
fest it is an immersive experience
meaning that it is three days
it involves not only going to see
stand-up but you have like other events
that comedians go to and we'll be at and
you can like mix with live podcasters
fighting pro wrestling there's [ __ ]
just there's mechanical bulls and
[ __ ] games and
beer pong tournaments and it's stupid
it's a fun thing it's a fun it's a
woodstock for people that like podcasts
the best podcast fans in the world best
comedy fans of the world they they they
love comedy they love every time i've
done a show it's gang fest it's always
been great and every time we've done a
live podcast it's gang fast yeah it's
always been great we're gonna do bastard
radio yeah it'll be fine i'm forcing you
it'll be fun no i'm doing it i told you
i would do it i know absolutely we'll do
it me and the great nick mullen uh i
think we're gonna do a state of the
industry address as bastard radio
the biggest topics from the year we're
going to break down
i just want to cover please
if we do a state of the industry address
we've got to carve out gringo poppy who
does what i want to do la i want to do
the rejection no no i want to do the
state of the la podcasting
as part of me as part of the state of
the industry addresses skankfest yeah
you and nick can do everything else yeah
everything else that's yours
you guys cover all of new york
television and film every podcast in the
world other than and you could also
comment on the state of the la
podcasting of course of course but i
would like to delete it my expertise i
just want to do the state of the la
podcast scene the great enduring scene
that will never die can we and it'll be
called the la podcasting the scene that
will never die and it will have the
photos of the people who are currently
in prison
tim can we play word association la
comic scene sure all right ready
you got to just fire it off don't be a
[ __ ] whitney cummings
drugs
bobby lee
korean
i mean it's the first thing that comes
to mind ryan cowan
ruffia
gringo poppy
kind of brilliant
kind of brilliantly
brilliantly funny in a way that no
comedy special has ever been because
it's it's mysterious in a way because
you're looking at it and you're going
like there's a lot of choices made and
you don't know why those choices were
made of course
of course yeah the comedy store uh
fine
that's it i can't name another word i
mean that's you know yeah well here's
what's amazing about the gringo poppy
this is what's truly amazing about it
okay
you're watching it
and you're in kind of it's it's
you're in a little bit of disbelief
because it is
i i wonder and i know he's trying to get
good at stand up and i respect the hell
out of that the question is what did it
have to be a special
no
that's the real question no
no it didn't yeah and i'm not one of
these guys like that's not that's on
brett that's not [ __ ] he's like a nice
guy and i know he's trying to be you
know like but the question is with that
particular thing you go did that have to
be
i said this on real-life podcast he
should have friends going because here's
the thing he's a charming dude right yes
um and he i think
i don't know at all you know but i think
there's probably something he's probably
a funny probably makes his friends laugh
right yeah i think that he's really
great at podcasting on that specific
show
for that audience yeah which they want
mma there's an audience of people in
america that want what he does and he
does it for them i am not that audience
of course but that's fair but that's
fair and here's yeah we we all go out
because i don't care about you everyone
stinks at comedy for the first five ten
years twenty thirty years there's a
[ __ ] minimum of five that's so if you
get good and start getting [ __ ] under
five five five you that's like fast
that's rare that's fast
one of the michael j like who's my best
friend and he's one of the people we're
talking about guys that like they got
like it's rare very rare yeah very rare
and you see it and you're like god damn
those guys got good and they got good
fast and they started getting things i
was pretty rare i got pretty good pretty
quickly but
again i didn't really pop until i
started doing this yeah of course that
was what i needed to do so but that's
the thing that's like the stand-up is
kind of gay
when we came up you stand up's kind of
gay and dumb yeah let's be honest it's
when i watch brendan do that
it's like i i i go here's a big tough
guy
who i should just see in a ferrari and
he should be able to rip people's faces
off with his catcher mid hands and i see
him running around the stage going oh
i go you're gay now you become gay you
were you why are you gay he was
a [ __ ] knight he was a no he was not
he was a knight
and now
and you go what why
what is this disease of cut maybe they
should come out next week what is it
you're six foot six you're an adonis you
could beat up 99 of the people who look
forward and [ __ ] women and you don't
have to [ __ ] these skanks at the comedy
store
[ __ ] hot women annie
and instead he's fully gay
on stage in dallas in front of 45 people
being like the lie
is
just
it's puzzling
it's uh yeah you don't need it when you
don't need it but that's the thing like
um
you know i i don't know
i feel bad [ __ ] on his comedy
because i don't [ __ ] on people's comedy
no no no me saying you shouldn't be a
comedian is the highest respect i can
pay you
if if i look at you and go you shouldn't
really do comedy it's me going
you are better than this i truly believe
he's like better than this yeah we all
know until you start to do this this was
nobody's a plan nobody no i was in a
little kid being like dude i want to
[ __ ] dance like a monkey for
strangers right and and pray to god that
they like me and that they react to my
words in a club yes or i won't feel
anything that's right that's crazy
that's a [ __ ] that's pathetic really
honestly if if aliens came down and
watched us doing comedy it's gay making
these songs i don't even mean gay like
having sex with men i mean like it's
just cringe yeah a little yeah it's a
little bit i feel embarrassed that i
need the validation of strangers and
others should too and even though we
make people happy it comes from the need
and i just feel like
knowing that
i would give up your happiness
for my happiness so everyone knows their
happiness is inconsequential in this
means nothing like what people say to me
they're like your podcast got me through
the quarantine i'm like you have no idea
what it's done for me
i'm like i'm glad it's helped you and it
makes me feel good that you've helped
them but i loved you
being honest your mom died
yeah i'm like i'm glad it helped you but
it really helped me
you know oh dude i'm [ __ ] having a
weird [ __ ] muscle spasm in my stomach
why because i did sit ups for the first
time ever
oh not ever like yesterday but but my
point is that when i tell somebody hey
stan it may not be for you it's not it
doesn't it's not an egg
no it's not and uh yeah whatever you
just don't need to put out specials
david tell puts out a special every
eight years and he's one of the greatest
of all time why is brandon shot putting
out two spells i don't even love the
special that i just shot and it's coming
out because here's the deal it's like
it's i wrote the material two years ago
you saw the jokes two years ago at
vinnie brandt's stress factory but my
whole thing is i want to do it live as
much as i can so by the time the special
comes out a lot of it's topical it's
relevant i don't love it i don't i
didn't love the audience
it is what it is but you know i
i
whatever people want to do with their
lives they can do yeah that's worse we
live in america more power to them yeah
we live in america more power to them
yeah for sure um